support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy in this video I kind of wanted to
discuss the different types of matter
that we can have swear and talk about
substances elements compounds and
mixtures so we mentioned before that
matter is basically anything that has
mass and volume it has mass and volume
and there are three states solids
liquids and gases right now matter you
can either have pure substances or you
can have mixtures let's talk about pure
substances first pure substances have a
fixed composition the composition is
fixed okay so that that might be
intuitive right pure substances fixed
composition that kind of makes sense
right within pure substances we have
elements that we have compounds we've
mentioned elements in the previous video
elements are basically we saw the
simplest type of matter right and cannot
be broken down further right
specifically elements are made of one
type of atom one type of atom will have
videos specifically on the structure of
an atom and things like that elements
can exist as an individual atom or as a
diatomic element okay so some atoms some
some elements they can just exist their
elemental form is just one atom of that
element so let's say like magnesium the
elemental form of magnesium is just
solid magnesium mg right no that's a
little s that's really tiny or something
like carbon like carbon is just solid
carbon just one atom of carbon gives you
is elemental carbon but there are some
elements that don't exist as just one
atom right some you need to have two
atoms for it for the elemental form and
there are actually seven diatomic
elements there are seven of them and you
should probably commit them to memory
the elemental form of hydrogen nitrogen
oxygen
fluorine chlorine bromine and iodine
they're all diatomic these are all the
elemental forms when we breathe in
oxygen gas it's not just one atom of
oxygen it's to a little subscript
indicates how many atoms there are of
that element so here we have hydrogen
nitrogen oxygen fluorine chlorine
bromine and iodine are all these of
these seven diatomic elements you should
probably commit them to memory when
you're studying chemistry is actually
pretty important to keep those in mind
so elements are made up of atoms and
atoms have three subatomic particles
which are protons positively charged
neutrons which have no charge and
electrons which are negatively charged
more on that later okay so now the other
type of pure substance is is compounds
right so compounds basically when we
have two or more elements in a fixed
parts by mass right combined in a fixed
parts by mass which basically means
we're going to have to have whole number
ratios of atoms to make up a compound
another thing about compounds is that
the properties of a compound differ from
the constituent components or elements
okay I'll explain what that means just a
second and the molecular mass of a
compound is the sum of the atomic masses
so basically when you have the atom is
of different elements coming together to
form something new but but that some new
thing that I will have a fixed
composition we're having different atoms
come together right we're going to make
a compound so so I'm give you some
examples an example might be like water
all people know that water is h2o right
h2o two atoms of hydrogen balint to one
atom of oxygen that gives you water now
we have a whole number of hydrogen atoms
in a whole number of oxygen atoms we
have two hydrogen's for every one oxygen
that we have we don't have one hydrogen
for half an oxygen atom we can't have
that we have fixed parts by mass right
and the molecular mass of water is the
sum of the atomic masses of hydrogen and
an oxygen here alright so we have two
hydrogen atoms one oxygen atom if we add
up the atomic masses we get the
molecular mass of water another
important thing is that the second
bullet point the properties differ from
constituent elements is that water is
made up of hydrogen atoms and of oxygen
atoms but water does not have this it's
a fixed that it's a pure substance that
has different properties than the
component elements themselves like
hydrogen gas and oxygen gas are not the
same as water right it's something
totally different carbon is a solid at
room temperature oxygen is a gas at room
temperature but if you put one carbon
atom and two oxygen atoms together you
can get carbon dioxide which is a gas
that we breathe out right that's totally
different from elements of carbon or
elemental oxygen right so these are
compounds that have bigs composition and
they're made up of two or more elements
right these are both Pacific ages to
something has more you can talk about
glucose for instance with sugar c6h12o6
right the point is that all these
conditions are satisfied these things
are all compounds within compounds there
are ionic compounds and covalent
compounds I'm going to go through this
fairly quickly because it's not crazy
important right now ionic compounds are
typically solids where you have cations
which are positively charged atoms and
anions which are negatively charged
atoms and what ends up happening is that
you have a metal and a nonmetal and
metals will lose electrons to the
nonmetals and on metals will gain them
so when the metals lose that negative
charge they become positively-charged
they become the cation and nonmetals
when they gain the electron they become
negatively charged so an example of this
is something like table salt right table
salt NaCl right sodium is the metal
chlorine is the nonmetal it's actually
sodium ends up having a plus charge
chlorine has a minus charge covalent
molecular compounds are basically what
happens when nonmetals combine so
instead of a metal and a nonmetal like
when it comes to ionic compounds we have
non metals combining and instead of
electrons being lost or gained the
electrons are simply shared so we have
the sharing of electrons going on so
some covalent or molecular compounds are
like the ones drawn up here water and
carbon dioxide okay so that's pure
substances now what about mixtures
mixtures when you have two or more
elements or compounds combined in
variable proportion okay so we don't
have fixed proportions or fixed ratios
when it comes to mixtures right and a
components of a mixture actually retain
their properties so so what's going on
here now I basically was just simply
before I get into her head erogenous
versus a modernist is that the idea of
variable
questions is that lets say i have a cup
of water here and a cup of water here
okay and i put a tablespoon what may be
one teaspoon of salt into this one and
then two teaspoons of salt into this one
these are both mixtures of salt and
water right but the proportions are
different right there's no fixed ratio
between this one teaspoon in this one
cup and these two teaspoons in it and
this one cup right there they're
different proportions okay also when I
put a mixed into the water the water
keeps its own properties and the and the
salt will keep its own properties right
because they're just they're just
physically combined they're not
chemically combined okay so within
mixtures we have heterogeneous mixtures
and homogeneous mixtures so
heterogeneous mixtures basically when
you have visibly separate parts oops
separate so um an example that I'd like
to think about of is like something
pretty macroscopic if we just imagine a
bunch of sand in a container and we put
marbles in it okay so let's say we have
some blue and pink marbles maybe you got
some blue marbles up here and then maybe
some pink marbles over here okay and
that's some paint Markel marbles down
here and the rest of the space is filled
in with sand Ryan this is just some some
jar or cup or something some sort of
container okay so this this brown stuff
that I'm drawing is just sand so if you
look at this right you can you can see
it there are marbles separate from the
sand right the parts of the mixture are
visibly separate okay another thing is
that the composition differs differs in
different regions of the mixtures what
does that mean it means that that for
instance like there's a high concentrate
i asked where of this portion of the
container versus a square
portion of the cantera or this area the
ridge of the container notice here I got
more marbles and I would up here right
here I have like three fourths of a
marble here I have four and a half maybe
so the composition is different in
different parts of this mixture that's
heterogeneous right that that means
basically that I have a different sort
of concentration of marbles in this area
versus this area it's not a uniform
throughout a homogeneous mixture on the
other hand there are no visible parts no
visibly separate parts and the compn the
composition is uniform throughout the
mixture going back to the example up
here about the water and actually just
draw down here if I have two cups of
water two cups of water same amount of
water and in one of them I put I put
nothing and then the other one I put I
put a teaspoon of salt NaCl sodium
chloride right and then I mix it you
would really be able to tell which one
is which right if I put them behind my
back mix them up you wouldnt 100% be
sure which one is which right because
when you when salt when you put salt in
water it dissolves fairly well right and
then the mixture is pretty much as clear
as as as pure water the parts are aren't
you not visibly separate and what ends
up happening is that it makes it so well
that one part of the of the salt water
would be just as salty as the another
part right the mixture would be uniform
so that's kind of the idea behind a
homogeneous mixture ok so I hope that
makes a little bit of sense now
what we can do is we can take mixture is
right and these the mixture mixtures are
basically when we put a bunch of pure
substances together and shake shake
things up right what we can do is we can
take mixtures and actually separate them
out to pure substances via physical
changes okay so I'm going to erase this
stuff here we can change separate them
with physical changes and some examples
are shown here filtration extraction
distillation crystallization
chromatography like a simple example is
that if we have a teaspoon of salt in
water what we could do is we could just
boil the wife we heat heat the water we
could boil the water out the wall the
water will go from liquid to gas which
is a physical change and the salt will
be left in the container that's a
physical change we're not changing the
identity of the salt or the identity of
the water we're just changing the form
or the state of matter specifically up
the water from liquid to gas so these
are some examples of physical changes I
might make video specifically on these
at some other time now one thing that's
of particular importance though is
talking about elements and compounds and
the inter converting between the two and
that is basically what chemical changes
are all right and that's where a lot of
chemistry is a lot of chemistry that
were going to talk about is basically
right here we're talking about taking
elements and compounds and
interconverting compounds and that's
really pretty much I want to say pretty
much but a lot of chemistry is studying
this particular idea here so I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful be sure
to video with the like and don't forget
to subscribe if you haven't already also
be sure to share the video then one of
you think might find it helpful thanks
and happy studying